[Música]
lo que vamos a hacer es un experimento
multitudinario ahora sigue a las
personas que están acá en el teatro
colon les cuento que llegó el momento de
que abran sus sobres vamos a discutir un
crimen discutir un asesinato que
involucra un incidente automovilístico
en una pequeña ciudad de la provincia de
buenos aires- fue hallado un cuerpo al
costado de la ruta
la víctima fue atropellada y abandonada
entre la noche del sábado y la madrugada
del domingo
la persona responsable se dio la fuga y
no asistió a la víctima
hay tres personas sospechosas de haber
cometido el crimen pero la policía no
tiene evidencia suficiente como para
detener a nadie este trágico incidente
ya hizo eco en toda la ciudad y los
vecinos empezaron a circular información
como por ejemplo y ahí van a encontrar
frases que son declaraciones testimonios
de esos vecinos acerca de las tres
personas sospechosas de esta historia
dan y gabi y agus
lo que tienen que hacer es leer
atentamente toda esa información y
decidir de manera individual qué persona
les parece que es más sospechosa
danny gabi o agus y además les pedimos
por favor que nos indiquen qué tan
seguros están de esa decisión en una
escala que va entre poco y muy seguros a
partir de este momento tienen un minuto
y medio para hacer eso adelante
muy bien se nos terminó el tiempo y con
esto termino la primera parte del
experimento y vamos rápidamente a ver
qué vamos a hacer en la segunda y última
parte del experimento ahora ya no vamos
a tomar decisiones a nivel individual
sino que vamos a trabajar en grupos de
tres pero los grupos no van a ser
cualquiera yo les voy a decir cómo van a
encontrarse y lo primero que tienen que
hacer es encontrar a dos personas que
están sentadas muy cerca de ustedes y
tienen el mismo número de participantes
por el momento solamente encuentren se y
cuando se encuentren por favor levanten
sus papeles
muchas gracias ya pueden bajar los
papeles tienen que hacer dos cosas nada
más número uno es que van a discutir
durante cinco minutos y llegar a una
conclusión consensuada a una conclusión
colectiva acerca de qué persona les
pareció más sospechosa y luego tienen
que decirnos además qué tan de acuerdo
están con esta decisión grupal vieron
que a veces cuando uno es parte de un
equipo siente que está de acuerdo con lo
que se discutió y a veces siente que no
está tan de acuerdo bueno les pedimos
por favor que nos indiquen qué tan de
acuerdo están a nivel individual que tan
de acuerdo están en una escala que va
entre poco y muy de acuerdo a partir de
este momento tienen cinco minutos para
discutir adelante
se terminó el tiempo se nos terminó el
tiempo para discutir las personas que ya
llegaron a una conclusión les recuerdo
que con esto se nos terminó el
experimento
[Aplausos]
[Música]
antes de terminar antes de irme quisiera
compartir con ustedes algunas de las
ideas e hipótesis que teníamos en este
experimento lo primero que hay que notar
es que les pedí que identificarán qué
persona les parecía más sospechosa entre
tres perfiles y que cada uno de los
perfiles tenía información positiva como
más bien sería más bien exoneran te como
si toma alcohol no maneja y también
tenían información negativa como por
ejemplo tiene la cédula verde vencida ok
si bien los tres perfiles tenían
información positiva y negativa había
uno de ellos que tenía más información
incriminante y era para todos los grupos
la misma persona adivinan quién es esa
persona que tenía más información
incriminante por favor digan no díganlo
bien alto
bueno la persona con más información
incriminante era dani
ahora bien en este momento yo ya sé que
más o menos la mitad de este auditorio
no me cree mucho y no me cree mucho
porque para darse cuenta que dani era la
persona con más información incriminante
tenían que no solamente trabajar en
equipo sino darse cuenta que tenían
frases repetidas y frases que no eran
repetidas y si ponían todas juntas la
información
bueno ahí uno se podía dar cuenta que
dani era la persona con más información
incriminante con esto no quiero decir
que dani es la respuesta correcta yo lo
que les pregunté es una opinión una
decisión que en definitiva es subjetiva
y ustedes podrían tener muy buenos
argumentos para decir que para usted es
la persona más sospechosa es davi o aus
pero lo que uno no querría es que esa
decisión por más subjetiva que sea está
influenciada o sesgada por como
accedieron a la información o como la
información estuvo distribuida dentro
del grupo por eso que teníamos dos
condiciones experimentales grupos del 1
al 500 tenían información completa es
decir podían ver todo
de todos los perfiles antes de decidir
los grupos del 500 1 al 1000 nosotros
decimos que tenían la información
distribuida pero es una esencia quiere
decir que sólo veían 6 frases por perfil
parte de esa información era compartida
aparte no era compartida y tenían la
tarea difícil de darse cuenta que dani
era la persona más incriminante pero
estos son mis ideas pero más allá de las
ideas quieren que intentemos ver los
resultados
levanta en la mano de los grupos 1 al
500 los que eligieron a danny solo los
que eligieron a danny
bueno vemos una mayoría bastante grande
ahora de los grupos 501 al 1000 levanten
la mano los que eligieron a danny
bastante menos bastante menos bueno lo
que creemos que pasa es que lo que
acaban de vivir en primera persona es
algo que nos pasa a los seres humanos
que se conoce como sesgos de información
compartida y es una tendencia que
tenemos a discutir aquello que tenemos
en común por sobre las cosas
distribuidas las cosas únicas que
tenemos que paradójicamente pueden ser
aquellas que nos hagan trabajar mejor
como equipo
saben cuál es el correlato cultural de
este sesgo qué es lo que pasa en la
sociedad que se parece a esto bueno es
la influencia que tienen los medios de
comunicación sobre nuestra sociedad
pensémoslo si nos interesa discutir
aquello que tenemos en común bueno vamos
a darle mucha importancia a aquello que
está en la radio en la tele en los
diarios y también obviamente en las
redes sociales porque es aquello que
justamente tenemos en común pero si eso
es así eso nos deja también en una
posición de vulnerabilidad cuando de
golpe nos enteramos que la información
que consumimos podría llegar a ser falsa
como por ejemplo en el caso de las
noticias falsas por eso es que además la
información también estaba dividida los
papeles que ustedes tenían estaban
divididos en otras dos condiciones
experimentales que son grupos con
información verificada a los cuales les
decíamos en un cartel que la información
había sido chequeado y que no había
información falsa y a la mitad le
dijimos lo opuesto
les dijimos que la información no había
sido verificada y justamente que podría
haber información falsa lo que estamos
tratando de ver es como la gente discute
la información como integra información
cuando duda de la veracidad de esa misma
esto no lo sabemos justamente son
hipótesis y para eso les pedimos que por
favor en este momento guarden los
papeles de nuevo en los sobres y a la
salida del teatro que se lo entreguen a
los voluntarios que los van a estar
esperando con mucha ansiedad van a ver y
por último quisiera concluir que esos
papeles justamente nos pueden llegar a
hacer entender por qué
concientizar a la gente acerca por
ejemplo del problema de las noticias
falsas puede llegar a dar lugar a
mejores debates democráticos muchas
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]
cómo